plan sud de barboutes 5 heures du matin
à l'arrière collezo senior lieutenant 23
ans le métier des armes il l'a appris
des C15 ans après le front de Carson il
est dans les tranchées du dombases
depuis six mois en première ligne à la
tête d'une cinquantaine d'hommes
ils ont utilisé plus d'artillerie mais
ici ils utilisent plus d'infanterie au
contact
nous avons constaté des rotations de
troupes il retire les Wagner et les
forces régulières sont en train
d'arriver c'était plus difficile quand
il n'y avait que Wagner parce qu'ils
avaient ordre d'avancer quoi qu'il
arrive il ne se soucie pas des pertes en
vie humaine
leur drone ont repéré de nouvelles
fortifications que les Russes sont en
train de creuser aux premières heures de
la journée dans les champs autour de la
cité ravagée
ces hommes vont opérer une batterie de
mortier leur tâche brisée Céline ennemis
les forces ukrainiennes qui doivent
stopper toute nouvelle avancée russe
depuis barmut mène des contre-attaques
sur sa périphérie
les positions de tir sont discrètement
installées à seulement 1 km des premiers
soldats procrément
vadiméo vivent sous terre depuis l'hiver
pas de rotation à l'arrière tous les
congés ont été annulés l'unité est à
pleine capacité
nous sommes venus ici en décembre le 3
décembre nous sommes arrivés dans le
Dombas la semaine prochaine ça fera 6
mois que nous sommes ici
de leur côté ils bombardement
de notre côté nous sommes plus
expérimentés plus rapides et nous avons
plus d'obus de mortier maintenant
la pénurie semble finie plus de
munitions car depuis quelques mois
l'Ukraine produit ses propres obus de
mortier
le drone est toujours en train de
chercher des cibles et puis nous
confirmerons la position exacte et
ensuite nous tirerons à la manœuvre et à
la visée causantine il revient d'une
formation militaire en Grande-Bretagne
ils ne nous ont pas dit l'endroit où
nous étions là-bas
c'était quelque part près de la mer
désormais la batterie peut tirer jusqu'à
50 obus par jour de quoi appuyer et
protéger l'infanterie qui avance petit à
petit
il consolide les gains pour eux la
contre-offensiver la au quotidien ce
n'est pas une percée fulgurante mais à
l'en grignotage du terrain
ça a déjà commencé
le mois dernier nous avons avancé de 100
mètres puis 300 mètres puis plus loin et
c'est aussi sur tout le long de cette
ligne de front ce ne sera pas rapide
cette fois il ne reculeront pas
facilement ils sont venus ici avec
beaucoup d'équipements beaucoup de chars
donc on ne pourra pas les repousser
facilement
par pression continue quelques poussées
des tirs du matin le rapport vient de
tomber l'acier endommagé les abris
russes et frapper la chair des hommes
nous avons touché une unité de soldats à
côté d'un petit bunker il venait juste
de commencer à creuser on les a vu deux
soldats qui travaillaient un troisième
dans le bunker et peut-être d'autres je
ne sais pas
sortons d'ici il ne faut pas traîner ils
peuvent y poster la réplique de l'ennemi
pour se venger des pertes subies il est
8h l'heure où j'y la campagne du gambas
des feux de l'artillerie des deux camps
ces hommes ont participé à l'offensive
sur Carson en septembre dernier ils sont
aujourd'hui déployés dans les alentours
de barnoud ils viennent de regagner un
kilomètre sur les lignes russes de quoi
redonner le moral ils espèrent que ces
contre-attaques menées sur les flancs
sur les prémices de la grande
contre-offensive